this is the most popular episode we do
every year it takes weeks of planning
I'm out 50 bucks because I got this new
jacket on we're all dressed up and why
because it is the Millie Awards it is
our endof year episode where we go
through about 15 categories right actors
they got the Oscars and musicians they
have the Grammys well what do business
people have they got the Millie Awards
and this is where we share a bunch of
different categories like our best and
worst Investments of the year you know
where do we take a big L on an
investment where do we win on or we'll
do a category like person we would most
bet it all on who would we if we have to
invest our whole net worth on somebody
who would we bet it on uh we got me Sam
and Andrew Wilkinson we're all here
we've been doing this for three years
now these episodes are always the
favorites this one went long we're going
to do it as a two-parter so in part one
we have categories like Billy of the
year uh best business that we think
somebody else should go do our favorite
moment from uh from the podcast this
year and the biggest change that we are
making personally in our game in 20 for
2024 four and in part two we have a
whole bunch of categories like our
favorite unsexy business and uh wild
predictions for next year so enjoy the
Millie Awards
[Music]
2023 okay what's up guys it's my
favorite episode of the Year Andrew wiin
is here Sam is here Sam you're looking
Dapper Andrew you're looking Dapper Sam
I gotta say the whole dressing well
thing
I'm bought in now I see it you don't
look like a science teacher you don't
look like you're from a different era
you just look sharp my friend yeah I
couldn't find my cuff links I thought I
was going to look like a farmer on this
thing thank God I found them right
before we
started do you guys remember how uh
Trump had like the Clemson football team
into the White House and they used like
the Lincoln gravy bowls for like
barbecue sauce that's how I feel right
now with this person who bought me
Tiffany Crystal for my wedding this is
the first time they're being used and
they're being used for Whole Foods brand
lacroy so shout out to that
person um Andrew you feeling good you
ready to do this thing feeling great
yeah I'm uh this is the best I've
dressed in years we're happy that you
did it here all right so this is the
Millie Awards we've done this this is
now Sean four years running we've done
this or is it three I think four so
maybe three I think it's three and we've
got we've got 11 or 12 or 13 categories
we're going to do favorite MFM guest
we're going to do Billy of the Year
biggest change we're making for 24
uh the person we bet it all on we're
going to do a bunch of different stuff
and we're going to try and go somewhat
fast for each category but I'm sure
we're going to have interesting stories
for each one Sean you want to kick it
off where do you want to go yeah
category one this is the Millie award
for our favorite MFM episode or guest of
the Year Sam start us off who you got
all right this was a tie it's not a tie
We're not gonna have ties but I'm gonna
say the top two that I had was Scott
Galloway so by the way we have a clip
that's gone viral on on YouTube where
it's a clip from the Scott Galloway pod
where he's talking about how much he
made I'm talking about how much I made
and people are just ragging on us both
so hard because they say that we sound
so depressed but I'm going to give it
number one to Kevin Ryan Kevin Ryan's
the founder of guilt Business Insider
mongod DB I think Kevin Ryan was the
best episode I think he was the most
wise person and well balanced person
we've had who's had crazy success you
know what else he did that I liked at
the end of the episode he was like
here's how I set up my company to
maximize um like kind of the gain I get
out of these companies and pay Rel
leased taxes and I'll tell you what no
rich guy ever says that no rich guy ever
tells you this is the structure I use
and he said it on on air he's like
here's what it does it lets me live in a
high cost State and I'm effectively only
paying 14% And my kids are only paying
0% on what they're getting out of our
our capital gains due to qsbs so he owns
the share he's like I only work on
projects that are qsbs eligible and
long-term capital gains I'm not looking
for uh cash flow or income because he's
like I got to a point where I I have
that like you know day-to-day needs
settled so you have to get to there he's
like but once you're there he's like you
um you take your qsbs you live in a high
cost State you then uh gift uh your
stock to your kids trust so you set up
kids trust you gift your stock to them
before you raise a financing round so
you're taking only like let's say 100K
out of your uh lifetime gift tax and
your kids now own qsbs eligible stock
when you sell you're going to end up
paying only the state tax so you'll pay4
% California or New York you'll pay no
federal um and then your kids will pay
0% wherever you know likely whenever
they they get it out of the trust uh at
their at their given point in time and
you're getting qsbs you know the $10
million taxfree for you times each of
your kids I can get to 50 million
taxfree if I got you know three or four
kids or whatever and I was like I don't
think they've got I don't think they
have qsbs in Canada land do they no we
don't have we have there's all sorts of
other stuff and benefits and stuff but
um there's a great saying on this stuff
um whales only harpoon whales only get
harpooned when they surface right he
just surfaced in a really obvious way
and you know there's just some anal
retentive IRS guy listening to the
stroking beard strike that all from the
record what uh what's yours Andrew uh my
favorite was Sarah Moore so Sarah Moore
uh she's a crazy story she um had a
really troubled childhood basically got
adopted by this wealthy family they
ended up putting her through Harvard
Business School and she went out and she
bought this business called
eggcartons.com and this story was just
incredible I feel like um so many people
hear these wild stories about tech bro
billionaires you know raising a bunch of
money and hitting it big making
trillions of dollars and I think her
story is much more realistic for a
normal person you know anyone she really
kind of uh is a testament to the fact
that anybody can teach thems business
and can go buy a business that is really
not rocket science and I loved how
simple and tactical all of her stuff was
uh she's so also said the she go I'm
trying to stay lowkey and under the
radar and I think it's been our one of
our most downloaded and viewed episodes
with like 500,000 listens to that
episode
whoops well so the smartest thing she
did is she like she did the um the
Michael Jordan like I'm retiring this is
the last thing like you know I'm never
going out again and now she it
immediately as soon as you said that in
the intro I was like I have to listen
right there's definitely episodes I kind
of check out of
I I I think that's a great one the uh by
the way there's a quick followup to that
cuz that sto that that story The Sarah
Mo story was falls in the category of
kind of like too good to be true so you
know look at all the elements it's
basically like here's this super hot
woman who grew up you know super poor
couldn't even get into college somehow
ends up at Harvard Business School there
must have been something happening there
a family like adopted her along the way
that's like the plot of the movie Blind
Side then it was buys a business but has
no money remember because she grew up
super poor so bought the business with
zero dollars cash down how she found the
business was she you know hired 50
interns off of Craigslist and like snuck
them into the Harvard uh business school
like library to work with her on this it
and you know buys this business Ed
carton.com for Millions it's a Millions
multi-million dollar business super
successful there's no pictures of her on
the internet there's no interviews of
her on the internet right we're like the
only guys whove like done this so there
was a lot there that like I came out be
thinking did I just get Elizabeth Holmes
I I might have oh God this I might be
part of the documentary here all right
let me uh let me at least make sure I
look good if this is gonna end up on
Netflix one day and she flew out after
the episode she's like I gotta meet you
so okay why uh and she's like I just I
need to know who I'm dealing with here
and so she flies out we go get lunch
here in the BBS uh in California she
flies all the way from Boston and
everything checked out it was if she is
Elizabeth holes she's the greatest
Elizabeth holes you've ever seen uh you
know she looks like what she said shows
like she told the story she showed me
the old photos like you know she
everything and she's like I'm so glad
you know people have been pretty
respectful because I said on the episode
please don't bother me um and we we did
a form instead of her like email address
like here type your questions in this
form and then we'll we'll answer the
form how many how many messages did she
get a lot she said after the first
appearance on it she got like like the
Netflix Bravo like other people had
reached out to be like can I do uh we
want to do a show on you or movie on you
wow all right well cudos to Sarah Mo
what what's your Sean all right my MFM
guest year this is gonna surprise you
guys is Connor price and Connor price is
a was a guy who was working in a
warehouse he was stacking boxes in our
friend's Warehouse in Ramone's warehouse
and he was like a wannabe rapper white
guy and you know like that's kind of
cliche but he actually made it and he
made it in a very interesting way he
figured out how to go viral on Tik Tok
and he was not a social media guy he
refused to even post on social media he
was too shy his wife was like you got to
do this it's a great way to get the word
out and let's just have some fun with it
she kind of became his like his manager
and they now have racked up I don't know
like a billion views on Tik Tok going
viral and the reason I say Conor price
is not just because that's an inspiring
story but but I took away one big lesson
of like the it's like I realized that
the puck has moved and I'll give you
guys the short version of it I think era
one of marketing was sort of like U let
me interrupt your programming in order
to tell you about my product right that
commercials that's like radio ads that's
how things used to work era two became
um hey let me send this to an influencer
they'll kind of hold up the product and
make a post about the product so now I'm
not interrupting your programming I'm
kind of using this trusted influencer um
but it's clearly you know still an ad
the content is buy this product it's
great and what Connor price is doing is
a little bit different he he creates a
little skit and in the middle of the the
payoff of the skit the hero of the skit
the one that saves the day is this dope
song and the 15 seconds of the dope song
and that gets people to go and actually
want to go find the product and now I
see this everywhere this is how Mr Beast
sells chocolate too he doesn't hold up
his candy bar and say this is a
delicious C bar you should go buy it he
says I recreated Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory and inside this Factory is he
makes like the product is baked into the
content the content is entertainment
around the product and now that I see
that I can't unsee it I see it
everywhere and it's part of my kind of
core business strategy now even our own
ads we changed like that instead of
saying we're gonna stop we're gonna tell
you about this thing we created a
segment called The Thrill of the shill
we we teach a lesson or an entertaining
story and then we tell you about the
product in that story and uh that's how
I think think marketing goes down cprice
got give a shout out to his wife too
just a total shark in the best possible
way AB yeah she was
Hardcore this data is wrong every
freaking time have you heard of
HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated W I can
see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a task
from 3 days ago I totally
missed hub spot grow
better all right you move to the next
one Billy of the year how do we describe
this one just a billionaire who's
fascinating it's just someone who's
balling out of control you don't even
have to be a billionaire you just have
to have that that billionaire strut the
ability to to walk with some Swagger and
play the game a little differently so
it's somebody who is Uber successful but
in a way that we really respect let's go
with Andrew first who you got so mine is
very obvious it's
um landline over there you still have a
landline dude you go public and you have
to install a landline the gate the gate
the the Gate of my house is like the
super old school system so I have a
landline just for that dude you you
better only be talking to presidence on
that thing yeah it's red it's red like
the bat phone um so mine is pretty
obvious it's Charlie Munger I think we
all know who he is uh for those of you
that don't he's Warren Buffett's
longtime business partner he just died
last week I think he was 15 days or
something short of his H 100th birthday
he was 99 and the guy was completely
sharp to the end I think a week before
he did an interview with Jesse or um
what's her name Becky quick um from CNBC
and I just want to tell you a story
about this guy this is how sharp this
guy was so Chris and I were having
dinner with him one night and all of a
sudden this guy bursts into the room and
he's like Charlie I got I'm doing a deal
right now I need to know uh an answer to
something and this guy walks in he's
like 30 years old and he just starts
rattling off a bunch of questions he's
like okay um we need to do it at 5.6%
interest for this many doors and Charlie
just asks a couple questions and they
says okay good cool and then the guy
just like says bye to us and leaves and
Charlie explains that it's this
neighborhood kid who he is a acidic Jew
tried to convert him to Judaism 20 years
ago going door Todo with a Bible uh with
with uh Bibles and they ended up
becoming friends he mentored him
they he started buying Apartments
Charlie backed him on this and now they
own a billion dooll real estate
portfolio of Los Angeles apartments and
he's just this neighborhood kid uh his
name is AI and uh and they built this
huge business together and Charlie
started doing this when he was like 90
years old his 90-year-old side hustle is
a billion dollar real estate portfolio
God damn it Andrew is this going to be
like a a couple that's been married for
80 years and they both die at the same
time is is Warren going to like is he uh
distraught you think in the same way a
marriage would be I don't know I mean
yeah Buffett's really old too and I
think um if you think about the
Actuarial tables they really don't have
much or Buffet wouldn't have much time
left but uh hopefully he keeps going for
a cou years I think he named or he said
he has a successor and everything lined
up but I wasn't sure if it going to be
like a marriage where like he's going to
go like next week but I guess we'll see
it's funny is they've had successors
since they were like 60 everyone's been
saying they'll die at any
time so they've gone they've gone a lot
longer than everyone thought
um all right mine's Palmer lucky the CEO
of andrel so we had Palmer lucky on I
think two years ago now it was an
amazing episode but here's why I like
Palmer lucky he says what you want to
say if you were a billionaire but you'd
be too afraid to say it and so he has
got a lot of really good quotes of him
he's kind of a loose cannon in in a few
ways like him and Jason calcinus have
gotten into it but frankly I love it so
he's got this great thing that he did he
spoke at a conference recently and he
goes do you guys know what the number
one profession that children want to be
it's social media influencer the next is
professional gamer the next is a
YouTuber and the problem is that you
can't tell kids to follow their dreams
when their dreams suck uh which is like
a great line and he goes do you know
what the number one dream for kids in
1971 in 1971 was it was an astronaut we
had just gone to the Moon these guys
were fighter pilots PhD mathematicians
Supermen who all were also really good
good-looking and well spoken it was the
ultimate American hero ideal for a kid
to see that and say that's what I want
to be okay then I say yes you we should
tell kids to follow their dream but when
it's social media influencers I should
tell we should tell them their their
dreams suck and don't follow their dream
so he's got these really like
articulated wonderful points that I
appreciate he dresses silly he's got a
mullet I'm a big Palmer lucky fan yeah I
like that one that's now two years in a
row Andrew gave him the nod last year
for Billy of the year and now Sam comes
in again with Palmer I love it he's uh
we got to get him back on man he was he
was really good on the pot he had super
interesting ideas and also like you said
speaks his mind he says that he flies
commercial and that he prefers to see to
sit by the bathroom he goes cuz that cuz
my my grand he goes my grandpa was a
pilot and I just love being around
everyone I don't truly believe that but
he cons continually claims that's true
what's yours
Sean um all right my Billy of the year
is going to be an entrepreneur who I
think has a I don't know how close they
are to the Billy number I think they're
probably close when you include their
wife that's a little hint for you I
wrote down a couple of bullet points on
why this person is a badass and you know
you're a badass when your couple bullet
points goes to the Roman numeral 13 let
me just read these off in Rapid
succession okay this person has been a
rapper an entrepreneur an investor an
author they are a motivational speaker
they have a badass wife who's even more
successful than them they somehow
married up even though they're super
successful themselves four kids and when
I called this person to prep for the
podcast they were on their way you know
they taking care of the kids uh taking
them to their soccer game yelling at at
them where's your shoes how you where
where'd you put your shoes yesterday and
that just told me they're they're
plugged in as a dad versus uh you know
four other people are raising their kids
um they own an NBA team they're part
owner in an NBA team they built a
coconut water brand a private jet
company they discovered David gogin
before he was David gaggin they they
actually invited David gogin to live in
their house and train them every single
day for 30 days
uh they like running so they created a
running festival they like pickles
they're creating a pickle brand they
created a fake Mount Everest because
he's like I can't go climb Everest but
I'll take this mountain I'll climb it 14
times and it's the same height as
Everest um he came on the Pod and had
one of the alltime classic lines about
some other competitor of his here he
goes keep the money warm you know thank
you for keeping the money warm for me
I'm coming and keep the money warm has
just it warms my soul uh he is just
having fun out here he's got great life
uh philosophies that about having
Adventures multiple times a year to to
have a life while lived he he also got
angry at me for asking him what his
monthly burn was yeah he called Sam out
for uh badgering him we had to cut it
out of the episode because it got Bader
him I didn't Badger him I I said I'll
ask whatever I want and I respect your I
respect you to say question sever
different ways until he finally Wilt he
didn't Wilt he was like that's personal
[__] Sam you're pissing me off and uh he
he is Jesse ller that is my Billy of the
year that's a good one yeah I uh I had
him on my list I thought you were gonna
pick him so I I backed off I think
Jesse's an amazing person he also has
this calendar I keep getting Facebook
ads for it and I'm gonna buy one where
he like said what did he say he goes I'm
50 years old I only have 30 Summers left
I'm planning exactly how I'm GNA spend
them exactly I think it was called big
ass calendar um all right category
number three what is the biggest change
you're making for 2024 but before we do
it we have to say what we said last year
Andrew you said being better at
responding to iMessage you were like
I've I've gotten my email system under
rep but you know you're like I have so
many text messages I'm bad at replying
it makes me feel like a bad person and a
bad friend uh Sam you said I'm gonna be
less of a
dictator uh you said I'm going to lead
this company without being a dictator
and being less metric obsessed I'm going
to be more Vibe driven more calm I
nailed it by the way just for the record
yeah I was going to say and I said
um I know I'm I don't know why I think I
said something else but I think I said
knowing when to use my impulsiveness and
when to ignore it um that so those were
our three Sam you want to go first so
you said you nailed it I nailed it i'
I've been way less metric focused I try
not to talk about sales or anything like
that you're a Vibe CEO I'm A vibe CEO
you know I'm not the CEO but my CEO is
metric driven but I'm not as much so I I
I calm down and I think I'm very easy to
be around at this moment but next year
so I'm making a few changes one I'm
gonna move eventually I think I'm gonna
do the most tuxedo guy tuxedo thing ever
I think I'm moving to like Greenwich
Connecticut that's not a joke that's
serious so that's gonna be a big change
but you know what I'm gonna do in 2024
is I'm going to get I'm trying gr
grayscale you know you guys know what
grayscale is that's when you there's
like a if you go to just Google it and
you'll see the directions on how to do
it but if you type in on your phone like
color you should see it where you can
switch your iPhone to only be black or
white so I'm doing that right now
because I've been using my phone to read
books to my daughter and I hate having
that bright all those colors because she
stares at them but the bigger switch I'm
going to do is I'm going to get a dumb
phone have you guys seen dumb phones
it's like a Nokia or a light phone I
cannot stand phone addiction it's really
bothering me I'm totally addicted and
I'm afraid to set a bad example example
for my children so this year I'm going
to move to a dumb phone which is similar
I guess to what you're saying Andrew
you're breaking up with email so two
well two thoughts on that before you
jump to that so one um the bright light
you get at night you want to actually
Peter AA recommends switching your phone
so that it's a red screen instead of
grayscale uh I can teach you how to do
that you tap your uh power button twice
and you can make it a shortcut to make
your screen red and red light doesn't
affect your night vision so that's what
I do um that said there's been studies
on um color and if you decolorize your
phone if you make a gray scale it's less
stimulating you're less likely to click
into stuff uh what I've done is actually
installed something called freedom and
freedom plus screen time basically block
everything I've been doing that but with
opal you know opal I think it's the same
thing yeah similar so it's like I
basically have no ability to get through
it like there's I I I have not been able
to figure it out and so I have no email
on my phone um I've blocked a lot of
texting say I've blocked every basically
basically every fun app uh and I feel
like an addict like I I feel like really
irritable I'm going through withdrawal
right now um but the change I'm trying
to make so I I nailed texting last year
I got this amazing app called text.com
which is basically like super human for
texts dude you've been twe you've been
tweeting out like links you're like like
you like refer five people and you get a
t-shirt or something I love it I love I
absolutely love it but the problem with
that is that I've now gotten so respons
iive with texts I'm so good with texts
that I'm getting more texts so you know
you send more emails you get more emails
I'm now getting too many texts and
because I built my email system last
year um I don't respond on email as fast
and so I'm getting more and more texts
so I have that problem the big thing I'm
trying to do this year is I'm trying to
break up with email fully so what I've
been doing for the last two weeks is I
can't access my email and my assistant
sends me screenshots literally of any
important email that she thinks I need
need to respond to and I just tell her
what to do with it and what's
interesting about that is when you're in
a flow State when you're working or
writing or doing something you'll often
have the thought oh [__] I have to
remember to send that email and so you
jump over to superhuman you send the
email and then you know you might see 10
other subject lines and before I know it
I'm like down a rabbit Trail reading
like a pachim mccormic newsletter or
responding to a problem or something
like that and so what I'm what I'm
hoping is that this new system will only
be the things that I absolutely need to
respond to and there's no additional
distraction so we we'll see how it works
let me just tell you two wonderful rich
guy things that Andrew just did that are
true rich guy things not these fake ass
not these wannabe rich guy things first
thing is he said you know what petera
recommends which is great because he
didn't say you know what my doctor Peter
Atia recommends he recomend it to me
yeah it recommends to me when I see him
because again he's my doctor so that was
the first great thing you did you didn't
brag when you could have bragged the
it's the words not said it's the dogs
that didn't bark right that that you
really gave yourself away as being a a
truly comfortable with yourself secure
person and I appreciate that the second
thing you're basically at the stage of
trump and others that are just like I
just get my email printed out and put on
my desk and I just quickly Mark with a
pen and then somebody goes I don't what
is email actually I actually don't
understand how the system works it just
shows up on my desk you're basically at
printed email and printed email is like
you got Louis Vuitton you got like you
know Birkin bags you got at the very top
of the luxury pyramid is printed email
and you're basically there you know
what's crazy though it's really not it's
not an inaccessible thing like um so I
have an assistant in the Philippines and
it's like $ thousand doll a month and
she does it right so it's like it is
something that a lot of people could be
it's not that it's inexpensive it takes
a certain level of confidence in your
lifestyle that you're not missing stuff
right you you are not lacking something
and so you're able to do this type of
system so what's interesting though is
I've done this I've been in this cycle
for 15 years right of getting
overwhelmed usually once a year I get
overwhelmed and I doll everything back
and Sam I've actually had a flip phone
I've tried the dumb phone at the end of
the day you need to order door door Dash
and Uber and do basic things so it
didn't work for me but I had this moment
where I was going through one of these
cycles and this was in
2010 and my friend asked me out for
sushi so I live in Victoria uh Canada
and I and Vancouver is about I don't
know a 35 minute flight away or a
two-hour fery away and so I go up for
sushi with my buddy and I'm in this mode
where I put my phone in my car and I
don't look at it so I um go have sushi
we have a great time we're catching up
at the end of the uh Sushi I get in my
car and I look at my phone and I've
received an email from Mark Zuckerberg
Mark Zuckerberg at the time was famous
but not famous famous not like he is
today and I had emailed him because I
heard he was coming to Vancouver and he
didn't respond for two days and then at
8 8 o'clock at night or seven o'clock at
night I got this email that said hey do
you want to go for a drink from him from
Zuck and there's and I checked this
email at 8:30 or 9 and there's literally
no way to get to Vancouver after 900
p.m. the fer leaves at 9:00 p.m. there's
no flights Etc and so I missed my opport
to go out for a drink with Mark
Zuckerberg oneon-one while he's out of
his element in my hometown and so I
always think about that story whenever I
block my email and do all these things I
still always think about that that's
insane that's so funny imagine somebody
who's like yeah I really want to make
this lifestyle shift it'll be good I'm
going to get off my phone but you know
what if Mark Zuckerberg just emails me
and I happened to be at Sushi and I
missed the one time he's in my hometown
in my neighborhood you know and then
like Jessica Beal was there afterwards
and she wanted to hang out but then I
just didn't have my phone on me but it
actually happened to that's incredible
it's a very sad story it's very
difficult life have you tried to like
catch up with him and be like Mark um
hey uh you know was doing a dumb phone
thing you know how it
is I'm walking around Meno Park until I
see you
uh you have to do the uh Andrew what I
want you to give up next year at least
when you're around Me Maybe Sean as well
is that stupid thing you you and Chris
always do where you can make everyone
put their credit cards in at the end of
a dinner you did that with me Sean and I
I won't name the other person but the
dinner that one time it was probably
$600 and I don't know this person this
person's finances but I I know they
aren't where you are and this guy had to
paid for like a $600 meal and I don't
want to be a [__] and be like call
everyone out funny thing is we were at
Sushi and this person doesn't eat fish
so they pay for the meal they don't even
eat
I think it's such an awkward it's born
so what basically the story is uh we
were all out for dinner and Chris and I
said hey you know instead of fighting
over the bill let's just all put our
credit cards in we'll let the the waiter
choose the card I would have fought you
we didn't have to fight what what I
noticed one of the weird things about
making money is that there's this weird
dynamic that happens where when the bill
comes if you pay the bill you're showing
off or you're implying they can't afford
it and if you don't pay the bill you're
an [__] because you can afford to and
so that's why we do
that well so Canadian of you yeah well
all right Sean what's
yours um what am I on oh biggest change
okay biggest change I'm making this is
something I started to do but I'm
doubling down on it
so this year I turned off two profit
streams that I think combined were
making like 1.2 two to 1.5 million a
year of profit I just turned them off
nothing was wrong with him I just turned
them off I lied actually there was
something wrong with them they were just
okay uh they were just okay meaning it
wasn't something I really loved to do
wasn't something I hated to do it was
making good money but it wasn't making
amazing money can you say what those are
yeah one of them was um my course so I I
was teaching this like power writing
course and uh you know I was only
teaching it basically two to three weeks
out of the year you know roughly 10 days
on average a year but it would generate
you know whatever a million bucks a year
of profit and um but I didn't like being
a course sales guy like I like teaching
but I'd rather just kind of like maybe
just do it for free on the Pod or
something like that do it do like a
master class episode instead um so I I
just decided I'm not doing it and I was
like okay that's just like less coming
in this year all right and that matters
to me uh so I'm like but I'm willing to
do that and I also just announced that
I'm shutting down my rolling fund so
I'll only be investing personally now
I'm not taking any more outside money um
just because it was like kind of another
thing to manage like here's a group of
investors I gota write these updates I
got to keep it like you know I got to
keep it organized oh should I do this
deal or should I not do this deal I just
decided I'm just gonna invest my own
money I don't I don't need to do this
anymore and with that comes like a stady
stream of fees and carry that would come
with a fund I turned it off again didn't
have to turn off just chose to turn off
and the reason why was I realized I was
talking to somebody that was I one day
like you know uh what's it like a
Christmas Carol movie where like he gets
visited by the ghosts uh and they're
like they kind of tell him the story
like I talked to one friend who's in a
bad relationship and they're not getting
out and I'm like dude this is not what
you want they're like yeah but it's not
terrible I'm like but not terrible isn't
your goal and they're like yeah but like
you know I don't know who else is out
there when if I meet somebody else then
maybe you know I'll feel and I'm like
you're just not going to beat somebody
else because you're dating this person
and then I met another person who's in a
job they did like same thing it wasn't a
terrible job so they didn't quit and
they would they'd be open to a better
job but they weren't seeing a better job
because they were so occupied with the
one that they had and so I just kind of
realized if you want something great you
got to make space for great you can't
just wait till your current thing gets
so bad you have to end it or that this
new amazing thing shows up at your
doorstep and it'll be obvious to switch
and you got to just say no to some some
things that are just okay in order to
literally create space so that a better
thing can come and land in your lap and
be there you have the time you have the
Mind share you have the availability to
take the meeting and something better
lands and that's exactly what's happened
this year better things have landed
because I've done that and so now I'm
like next year what else is there that's
like kind of in that middle tier it's
good not great bucket that I should just
I should just get out what's it going to
be um I'm thinking about what that what
that might look like I I don't want to
say just yet but yeah there's there's
maybe some other things I could do to
free up more time or create some space
what do you think about that I actually
well I um yeah it's funny you mentioned
that so one of the problems with having
a fund or raising money is that you owe
people things right there's people that
have given you millions of dollars and I
actually had a moment yesterday where I
had a really busy day and I woke up and
I actually felt really excited and
creative and I made this big list of all
these things I wanted to dig into that I
was excited to learn about and work on
and then um there's a really wonderful
guy who invested in uh a fund that we
raised and he gave us I think 5 million
bucks or something and he wanted to get
on the phone and understand what was
going on with an investment that we made
and so me and Chris had to stop
everything we're doing and talk to him
and we had a you know we had a really
nice chat with him but it interrupted my
flow state it interrupted what I really
wanted to be doing in my day and the
problem with raising money is that at
the end of the day there's people who
can call you and you owe it to answer
the phone and they can interrupt you at
any given time and especially in a
rolling fund there's like 50 of those
people and so I feel the same way I
really think that um when you give your
time to something like that you're
taking away from something
else but that's we're going to get to
best investment or maybe we can go right
there but some of the things that you're
doing contradict that and same with
me totally yeah like I'm doing the
Twitter subscribers for example but the
thing about it is that I actually enjoy
a I don't nobody can email me say I'm a
Twitter subscriber I demand your time
I've made it very clear that I'm only
doing an AMA once a month I don't
respond to tweets necessarily I don't
guarantee any response and so most
months I spend an hour doing an AMA that
I find really fun anyway so for now I'm
going to continue doing that but um but
I've certainly considered that oh by the
way I have an up I have an update on my
biggest change from last year that IID
said where I was gonna be less I was
gonna learned when to use my
impulsiveness and when not to totally
failed at that um we there was a
business idea that we had that we were
like oh maybe we should do this business
and I was like here's the reasons why
I'm super excited about it but I was
like you know what old Sean would have
just started it now new Sean here's what
I'm gonna do this business isn't going
anywhere I'm gonna give myself a twoe
cooldown period where I've done all the
meetings I'm kind of like I know what's
there I have the information I need but
I still have to decide is this a
business because you you know you don't
date a business you kind of marry a
business for like at least a couple
years and so I said let me get my a twoe
cool down period to get off the
impulsiveness and I made it two days
into the impulsiveness period before I
had my first customer and I was running
and it was so good and I was like oh I
definitely didn't do the thing that I
would have advised me to do which is to
say if you still want to do this in two
weeks then you know this is a great
business for you and uh I I kind of
failed at that I got to admit so still
working on that one I'm gonna keep that
one on the list for this year and
impossibly shut down your rolling fun um
let's do person you'd bet it all on uh
so mine was between two of our guests
actually Jason yanowitz and Austin Reef
Jason yanowitz started blockworks it's a
crypto Media company I don't even like
crypto but I love Jason and I love his
Media Company he scaled it to I don't
know tens of millions in revenue and
then Austin Reef started morning Brew
who was my competitor now I've gotten
really close to him because he's in my
core group at Hampton but I'm gonna give
it to Austin because he's already sold
most of his business morning Brew I
think he was 26 when he sold it at a 75
million doll valuation the company now
is doing High eight figures in Revenue I
think whatever Austin Reef does I would
I would blindly put money in I I would I
would invest in him blindly wow that's
not who I thought you would pick
Austin's amazing but uh that's a you've
come full circle you're you your former
competitor now turned dare I say it hero
well look I love these people that have
the perfect balance of optimism and
pessimism you know like they're like
optimistically PES P pessimist like
where they think something amazing are
is going to happen but they're fairly
conservative and they plan for the
downside so uh he's interesting to me
cool who you got Andrew who would you
bet it all on so mine's not really a
business person necessarily um you know
I've been thinking a lot about like AI
disruption and I think that if I had to
bet it all on one business that would be
incredibly hard because I think in AI
there's so many second order and third
order consequences and levels of
disruption so my thought was actually if
I could just be an investor in a
podcaster someone with a personal
Monopoly and my idea was Andrew huberman
so I think he's got a incredible brand
uh and he's doing the thing that he
loves and is kind of made for he's
insanely likable he loves talking to all
these interesting people about all these
interesting things people have this
incredible affinity for him and they
will basically do anything that he says
if people advertise with him or he talks
about a product everyone will buy it
which means that his ads like we tried
to buy an ad for Aeropress a year ago we
just got an ad for Aero press literally
yesterday uh and I think we paid some
you know very high number because his
audience is huge did you see results
from it yet uh I don't know yet I can
report back um but anyway he his
business I'm like that is a completely
undisrupted business unless he gets hit
by a bus or something the best line was
from Rob deerdick we asked him how much
it cost to advertise momentus uh on the
pod on on huberman's pod and he goes I
don't remember how much it was but I
could tell you whatever it was it
probably wasn't enough cuz he moved the
needle for us that
much yeah that's amazing all right my uh
person I'd bet at
all Sam are you sitting down yeah it's
you bro me it would be you it would be
you and let me tell you why let me tell
you why not just for the reasons that
you think you're talented but there's a
lot of talented people you're smart but
there's a lot of smart people out there
I this year have really come to
appreciate more than ever and I think
it's because I've moved out of the I'm
going to be CEO and operator role to
more like I'm going to be investor uh
and other trust other people to operate
uh you know these businesses that we own
um you the underrated trait that I had
been severely underweighting in my
little mental model
was like are is this person going to be
focused are they going to get distracted
is this person going to be loyal and are
they going to take this seriously and
when it comes to that like we have a lot
of friends that are you know they're
talented and they're successful but they
have shiny object syndrome I'm one of
them uh we have a lot of people that
will uh if they if they do something
they kind of know they got 10 more shots
on goal and they're just going to keep
trying different stuff until they figure
out the little thing that works every
time you talk to them if you catch up
with them every quarter they're GNA have
a new narrative you're not like that and
I've now learned that people like that
they just win and the PE the people uh
the people who are steady and and I and
I feel like to have a certain level of
seriousness about them uh when it comes
to doing something like I don't really
care what it is like when you were
writing your blog posts for the hustle
early on even before the newsletter just
like yeah we're going to write a blog
post that needs to get a bunch of people
to um subscribe and follow us and you
took it incredibly seriously and when
you're hosting events you took it
incredibly seriously and when you're
doing Hampton you take it incredibly
seriously you do one thing and you take
it very very seriously and if I'm going
to bet it all on somebody that's really
what I want is a certain level of
seriousness it's something I it's a
trait I've come to admire like we hired
a CMO into our e-commerce business and
uh this guy Chris and he's amazing uh
not because he's the most talented
marketer and like if you go on Twitter
every day there's these like Ecom guys I
don't know if you guys see this or just
my feed of guys just bragging about this
like campaign they did and this new ad
technique they did and he's not like
that he's just blocking and tackling
every day with a certain level of
seriousness and the beautiful thing is I
know this guy's going to stay focused
and only work on this he does doesn't
have three side hustles he doesn't have
his own podcast and rolling fund he's
just going to stay focused on this for
the next four years and when he does
that and he takes it seriously and he's
gonna like do all the obvious things
he's going to win bigger than the kind
of like talented person who's all over
the place and I know that's a big
contrast to me because I'm more of the
talented person who's all over the place
but I've seen the value in the other
side now and I'm like that's who I need
to surround myself with because those
people win well I appreciate you I love
the love and I love you for saying that
that's very kind I um
I we had a m like we did these MFM
meetups recently um and I called in one
to to one last night Sean and apparently
the thing is is they put on their badge
who they like more you or me and they'll
never tear us apart bro I don't even
want to know the results They'll Never
Tear Us Apart obviously every brown
person every Indian person had
shot but I was shocked maybe I shouldn't
have been shocked you were you were a
fan favorite so by you liking me and
them liking you they are now my fans too
maybe I hope um but I appreciate that
thank you very much I think that um
focus will change your game Sean and if
you want you know like this is a little
crude but you know how you're supposed
to like rub one out before you have
before you like do something bad with
your with someone that you're not
supposed to if you want love you you
could do that to me I will help you I'll
be your
hand I'll keep you focused I don't know
what that offer was but that was kind I
think
um I just offered my hand to you yeah I
got you all right um all right what's
the next one best business for someone
else to go into yeah what what's a great
business idea that someone else should
go do do you know what we said last year
I think mine was a washer and a washer
and dryer that's two in one uh Andrew
said empty empty leg flights and then
Sean said school for Starving Artists
like turn art into commercial things for
example
photographers yeah all right so I don't
think anybody did any of those three so
uh what do we got this year boys we got
we gotta step it up I've got a pretty I
think it's practical so since the
beginning of this pod Sean I've said
that I think privacy is going to be more
important and it's G that's is a mega
Trend I said that uh things like Duck
Duck Go are going to get a lot bigger I
think they have gotten huge but not as
big as I thought because it hasn't been
easier than it's been more like a a
vitamin not necessarily a painkiller I
still think uh it's going to get big
that that space and I think in
particular what you're going to see is
companies who are tailored for it's
going to start with first like
Executives and people like us who are
have audiences and it's going to be
something like where they protect your
information online so I've gotten like
I've signed up for a few of these
services and I'm alerted if one of my uh
passwords gets hacked or they'll say
like hey um we know where you live
because because we saw you post a
picture of your car and then we did
Google Maps and we see your car in front
of the house and we just predicted where
you live and we and and and so I'm using
a bunch of these I'm testing a lot of
them out I think these are going to be
really popular so for example cyber
health. Co I've not used these guys yet
but I like like the premise that they
provide but I think what's going to
happen is there's going to be it's going
to start with like five or $10,000 a
year services that are a little bit more
towards Executives and then it's going
to Trail down and I think genz is going
to be all about privacy in the next 10
years so that's what I'm interested D
that's a great one I like that one a lot
I I totally agree with you this feels a
little semi Glu TIY like uh hey wait is
Sam on to something here I think you I
think he might be on to something Andrew
what you got what's the best business
for someone else to go do so I love this
one I think I would do this if um if I
was going to start a business and uh my
idea is AI Tinder so imagine you go on
Tinder so so the what gummy thing about
this is um Dolly and all these image
generation tools can now create photo
realistic images
and I don't know if you guys have seen
them but there's now Instagram
influencers um who are beautiful men and
women who make $10,000 a month on
Instagram dude I just kept getting this
I kept getting this lady come up with my
Twitter and I'm like this lady's very
attractive what's her story like why do
I keep getting the same person going on
my story and it they don't say she was
fake but I'm like this is definitely
fake this person's not real then I had
to Google it and and she was fake yeah I
mean and and they they can I mean it
basically you can look at the image and
almost not know so
my here's my idea so you basically
generate um like thousands and thousands
and thousands of fake digital men and
women and then you have Tinder and you
basically um you make it like a casino
right so you're swap you're swiping and
let's say you match with a a really hot
digital girl and then you have to text
with her and there's some sort of
algorithm where you have to win her over
to exchange photos and start talking or
whatever and I just think if you gamify
dating right I mean it's kind of it's
something that like you know people in
relationships can even do this right
it's just kind of like scratching an
itch I think that's something that would
just absolutely blow up but you're
saying they know it's fake right you're
saying you know it's fake the game is to
it's almost like you know flirting as
you're getting better and like people
might see this as like creepy and it's
like no these Bots can train people how
to not be creepy right because you're
never going to get another photo if
you're
creepy we've talked about replica do you
remember replica it was like a digital
girlfriend or boy
and they like changed part of their
algorithm or something about like what
they allowed people to talk about and
one of one of the guys killed himself
like one of the customers killed himself
like these people fell in love with
these women these fake women so it's
pretty
wild yeah that's crazy all right uh best
business for someone else to go do okay
I had a couple ideas I think anything in
the guns and ammo space I think is a
great one um but I didn't want to pick
that one I think distress Venture
Capital Andrew I think you guys are on
top of this which is a bunch of
companies that are good products have
revenues but they are not going to be
able to raise their next round and
they're going to go die and you know
creating a business around that is good
but the one I picked
is Tik Tock shops so I don't know if you
guys are paying attention to this but
the number one book in the world right
now do you know what it is it's the
shadow work Journal number one book in
the world what is the shadoww work
Journal you ask well it's this goddamn
book that you can't you is just going
crazy on Tik Tok it's basically and what
it is is uh Tik Tok not just launched
the ability to shop they launched the
ability for anybody to be an affiliate
of any product without having a
relationship with the company so created
this giant like you know Network sales
thing it's like almost like an MLM uh
Tik Tok is turned into a giant MLM so
basically you can as a Creator just find
a product in the shop that's eligible
for commission you make a video about it
and you get a commission every time they
go buy it that's why this this journal
is the number one product in the world
this sold over half a million copies of
this journal yeah it's sold Tik Tok
tells you how many it's sold half a
million this is crazy and that's that's
through the Tik Tok shop then you have
Amazon it's the number one book on
Amazon too so you add another half a
million on that right that that's easily
a million copies sold of this of this
one journal and this is like in a two
and a half three month span this is not
very long and um you know I'm the type
of person where I meet people like I
meet Moyes and uh you know he's like
yeah I did Facebook uh ads for Native
deodorant I like okay well what worked
it's like yeah back then you know the
clicks were just super cheap there
weren't very many people advertising on
Facebook especially a product like this
it was just mobile games or something
and you're like damn man that was the
The Glory era of Facebook ads now it's
all so expensive now it's so competitive
but you know if I was doing this in 2012
that was the time and you know oh I wish
I bought Bitcoin back in 2011 or 2012
when my friend first mentioned it back
it was you know
$130 that was the time and I always wish
I was there back in the time well guess
what there's a Golden Arrow that's
happening right now and it's Tik Tok
shops right T Tik Tok shops is currently
in that like it's very cheap it's not
that saturated and Tik Tok is very
motivated to promote these things and
Tik Tok customers are not like fully
acclimated to the fact that now a bunch
of the Tik toks they see are selling
products and so the conversion rates
going to be higher and these windows
don't last for very long but they do
last you know and when you you can go
make hay during these periods and so I
think if I was uh you know 23 years old
there's nothing else I would rather be
doing than trying to create something
that's going to sell through the Tik Tok
shop platform Tik Tok is even paying for
like they'll subsidize your product so
if you have a $60 product it'll be for
sale for $30 but you're still getting 60
because Tik Tok is subsidizing products
that they want to promote and uh and
giving you the full value of them so
you're getting Tik Tok to pay for half
the half the product sometimes or or 30%
of the product sometimes it's pretty
insane yeah this is wild and I see that
guy Isaac from mini Katan or whatever
what's it called Katana yeah mini katana
like sharing all of his t TI Tok shop
details and it's wild it's pretty crazy
kind of like when the iPhone came out
people start making apps for the App
Store but you can see the charts you can
see what's getting downloaded and the
same thing with shops you can go see
what's selling well and how many units
it's sold and you can kind of either use
that to either create a competitor or
like just sort of like abstract away and
be like oh it's this type of product
that's doing well at this price point
that's doing well on Tik Tok let me go
let me go after that all right that is
part one I got to go take a pee break
get some water take a rest but we got so
many trophies still on the table that
have to be given out for the Millie
Awards we got six or seven of my
favorite categories we saved the best
stuff for last so after this go listen
to part two of the 2023 Millie
[Music]
Awards